[Music]
oh god you ready to cringe
logan paul i already am
i already am now with this image logan
paul reads a pre a statement that he
wrote
you ready
me 25 years to realize this
it is not enough to be not racist
you have to be anti-racist yes
condemn those who feign superiority
because of the color of their skin
friends
hold friends accountable hold your
family accountable hold yourself
accountable and most importantly we must
hold our authorities accountable police
officers politicians
and for those who do not think white
privilege exists you are [ __ ] blind
you are delusional and you are part of
the problem all right give all your
money to black people
yeah halo that's a good that's a good
point why don't you do that
give all your money to black people
uh logan has no black co-host by the way
anytime you want to [ __ ] preach that
white privilege [ __ ] to me
logan paul i i'm i'm personally inviting
logan paul
to come to the state of florida
all right and i will take you on a
[ __ ] guided tour of pascal county you
want to talk about white privilege you
and i will drive around newport richie
holiday
you know what i mean we'll go up u.s 19
i'll take you to [ __ ]
desire or whatever the [ __ ] they're
calling that place now
i'll drive you around the [ __ ] motel
sixes and you show me all the oppressed
black people there it is almost 85
percent white county in florida and it
is filled with the most sub-human
garbage [ __ ] zombies you've ever seen
in your life
that is my offer to you logan paul you
you paid for the plane ticket all right
and i'll i'll i'll be your friend we'll
take you out to dinner we'll host and
i'll take you to [ __ ] newport richie
and then you can you can preach white
privilege to me while i show you the
[ __ ] suffering in those streets
um oh hey let's go to let's go to the
applebee's in deltona
let's go you want to do that what do you
think the pr hear me out on this right
i'm not against your idea okay problem
with that is probably going to be a long
wait time that is a very popular app
well because after after midnight it
turns into club apple because there's
nothing no this is for real there's no
there's no i know yeah the one thing
that's small towns yeah i was at one of
those ones
hey you get laid there if you're if
you're smart though dollar readers are
still a dollar etas you don't want to
though
fair enough
um
count on zero hands the amount of times
that i have feared for my life at a
routine traffic stop that has never
happened half of the reason i'm able to
get away with some of my hooligan [ __ ] i
do in my vlogs how many times because i
was the [ __ ] ford raptor or a [ __ ]
lamborghini when you were being pulled
over in a routine traffic stop [ __ ] you
dude but if i i [ __ ] can't stand
these [ __ ] d i because because
because they're all fake man
logan paul became famous at what age 18
maybe
like when was his first ballgame falling
in 2013.
so
paul's 27 brother was already famous
he just made him famous so shut up
you i hate these [ __ ] people that
think that because he's white and life
was easy for him that everybody who's
white the life's easier it's it's such
it's such a [ __ ] cop-out it is it is
such a it is such a like black people
are
and again it's always what logan paul is
always more racist than anything we'll
ever say which is like black people are
dumb and stupid and they're and and they
need our help because they're dumb and
it's and and cops are mean to them
bro logan come on man i know you're
trying to be i know you're trying to be
a heel and stuff but like if you're
trying to get go away heat this how you
[ __ ] do it you know
it's unbelievable to me logan talks
about how he benefited from white
privilege but of course like you said
marsh he's not going to give all his
money away to black people though right
no
right
by the way is any they need to be poor
and by the way uh logan nobody has
actually beat up more black people than
real life than you i've seen your boxing
career yeah you love beating up blacks
as a matter of fact physically assault
them every day people pay you people pay
you money to beat up black people
you're contracted out to beat up black
people you're a hit man
that's what you are and by the way logan
you little boxing matches um
as somebody who's seen the great white
hype at least like five times in my life
um
you don't think that
you made all that money playing off of
the race hype
you don't think that that's why people
meme [ __ ] i mean i saw a lot of videos
on on both black twitter and white
twitter
with very divisive comments about you
that's what sells tickets
it's that's what makes money yeah
the whole movie the great white hype was
about that was the fact that they needed
the same thing with rocky they were like
yeah i get it we could box like the best
guy in the world
but i'd rather you find me a white boy
you know what i mean like that has been
the story you you have made a fortune in
a business that made a hundred percent
of its money on racial division they
always were like all right the champs
this big black dude find me some italian
or some irish bruiser from massachusetts
with a decent record because then all
the [ __ ] buy rates went up because
then all the whites and the black people
are like oh man i'll put my money on a
white boy like
come on man
but it it's amazing to me like i i'm i'm
not gonna be i'm not gonna be [ __ ]
talked down to all right by the by the
suicide forest brotherly duo you know
what i mean like [ __ ] you bro how
[ __ ] dare you all right and why don't
we talk you know it really it really is
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] um
hilarious that he's yeah white privilege
white privilege is that why on april 9th
2021 your brother uh was accused of
sexual assault huh what about that
apparently did you know justine paradise
allegedly paul forced her into oral sex
and touched her without consent during
an incident at the team house team 10
house in 2019 hey hey hey logan did jake
use his white privilege to mouth [ __ ]
somebody in a content house
allegedly allegedly a co-op being the
college into her i'm asking i don't i
don't have this i don't know
i don't have to say allegedly i'm just
looking out for my boy i'm asking a
question
i'm asking did that happen they could
say no
uh paul responded to the accusations say
sexual assault accusations aren't
something that i or anyone should ever
take lightly hey are we gonna ask why
the f why the fbi raided your home and
we never really knew why remember that
remember when the fbi raided the paul's
homes i remember that
what happened
huh
didn't the fbi raid your house because
you attended a riot in arizona and you
guys were accused of throwing molotov
cocktails
yeah didn't you guys didn't i watch you
[ __ ] grab stall and vodka
out of like a [ __ ] it's like a moe's
or something too it was one of those
like uh
southwestern chain restaurants remember
that when they were at the mall that
video of like somebody passing off a
bottle
it's it's just it's these [ __ ] these
these people are always like that it's
like yeah [ __ ] that's right yell at
white people now there's white privilege
now nobody did anything right now no one
doing anything but you're you know
you're in by the way your entire
audience is white buddy go look at your
[ __ ] social blade demographics who do
you think watches your videos white
dudes
half of the reason i'm able to get away
with some of my hooligan [ __ ] i do in my
vlogs is because i'm a white kid
i'm confident that i do not have to fear
for my life should the cops show up
yeah oh you're right that's why eric
andre routinely gets murdered
and every time he films this guy and he
does more hooligan [ __ ] than you do
yeah
[ __ ]
he's lucky he didn't get killed just the
pizza ball sketch remember the black the
black kid that was going in the telling
people he was gay and he was hitting him
at walmart that was a black kid that was
doing that so shut the [ __ ] up
when he's like acknowledged yeah
your privilege
i believe we're going to a protest today
you can bet your [ __ ] ass i'll be in
the front line
your squirtle really like
sends this [ __ ] serious vibe bro i'm
so sick of these [ __ ] people acting
like they're taking a hard line in the
sand like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
say it right now i don't give a [ __ ] if
they freeze my bank account and lock me
up with those january six people i'm
gonna say it right now okay racism
exists and white privilege is real
i don't care who [ __ ] hears me say it
bro hear me out hear me out marsh i
don't care if every major corporation
agrees with me
i don't care if every single major
corporation especially my sponsors agree
with me on this
all right hurting black people's wrong
that's not true they disagree with you
universally just only their middle
eastern dish uh divisions oh that's a
good point
hey can i see the chinese cut of the
logan paul show please
it's just the hanging japanese woman in
the forest
that's the only that's the only footage
of logan paul that they allow in china
yeah is the one where he's in the
japanese suicide forest
knowing all this about america
it's racially charged background
just a [ __ ] pair of blue legs hanging
behind him
[ __ ] it like the grudge
it's inability to truly treat humans i'm
gonna say this even though everyone's
already said it like five years ago i'm
gonna repeat talking points that now
they're super safe to say
all right i don't care what anybody
thinks about me all right black lives
matter
you hear me yeah guys look i'm gonna say
this right now and i really hope we
don't get nuked off youtube oh boy here
we go hot take coming this is gonna blow
shaming is wrong
wow
jesus christ hey you know what i don't
care i don't give a [ __ ] if they take
our pay pal away i'm gonna say it
lizzo's big and beautiful
come at me she didn't look like a [ __ ]
coming out of an [ __ ] no she didn't
not at all she didn't like a burnt state
puff marshmallow man
okay she's beautiful
as equals even after 244 years since its
inception
we must now work
you know no matter how famous logan paul
is you forget he's just in his 20s like
you know he's just a dumb idiot yeah and
i just look back and i'm like yeah this
is like dumb [ __ ] i would have done in
my 20s when i was a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what i mean like no matter no level
of fame makes you smarter if anything it
makes you stupider because if you've
been famous since you've been a teenager
have you ever had any real adversity to
overcome you know what i mean it makes
you more stupider even when he wasn't
famous his brother was famous enough to
bail him out of [ __ ] like
so you know like my point is just like i
love i love this yellow people you don't
have white privilege logan you have jake
paul was my older brother privilege yeah
[ __ ] seriously
the same way brendan chubb has joe
rogan's my friend privilege
exactly towards finding the solution and
if you are an influencer or a celebrity
friend of mine we're influencers that's
us he's talking to us maurice let's hear
what he has to say let's hear him out
and i hope you are using your platform
to continue to spread the message of
solidarity and unity of white people yes
got it write it down
with you write it down solidarity for
white people we're listening more right
no more
ten times a day
for years virginia first room looks like
jack nicholson's in the shining when he
was
it's more like the opening of seven but
true same thing
i do not have all the answers but i know
you don't have any answers
you have zero answers you're a 20
something year old [ __ ] exactly it's
the same you're just a dummy bro
you're not smart and i get it i know
you're you just forget people forget his
age
we must now reverse engineer the system
as guys listen to me we have to reverse
engineer the system
all right
what does that mean it's more of that
commie gobbledygook
collective
we must open our eyes and realize that
there is only one race
the white race write that down virgie he
said there's only one race to white
it looks like the room from seven got it
okay definitely in there hey logan 1488
paul i hear you buddy we all wink wink
and that is the human right you're
laying down yeah
on behalf of brianna taylor
[Music]
you mean
you mean that chick that that they found
a dead body in her rental car like a
week before they did that no knock
warrant well hold on at least he's not
going to bring up george floyd
is that true we yeah what
you didn't know that no i i mean i knew
about the drug dealer and the warrant
but yeah no she rented a there was a car
rented in her name and they found a
[ __ ] dead body in it
we must change
on behalf of ahmed aubry we must advance
and on behalf of george floyd
[Music]
got it
george floyd and the hundreds of others
you must grab a banana and dance
it's true
that's not
i want it on record whenever you bring
that up i don't ever want to get in
trouble for saying that i don't want
anybody ever say that's a racist comment
the man literally spent his last joyful
moments
dancing with banana in his hand yep and
on behalf of george floyd and the
hundreds of others who have been unjust
and the millions watching it hopefully
murdered in this country
we must evolve i mean
all right man that's cool you said
nothing though we watched a two-minute
video of yours and he talked so much he
said nothing but i mean not even he said
a little bit he said
nothing
no it's like the [ __ ] it's like the
head of sailor movie at no point
did you say